next up charlie is so cool like which
this week contains mild language and
immaturity from the start what English
words do you already know bollocks
this is my friend Michael Aranda he's
from America and sees he's staying with
me here at the moment yesterday I
decided to try and teach him how to
speak English this video you're about to
see is the result of that enjoy you know
an aubergine is a what and fishing I
don't even understand what you're saying
aubergine aubergine aubergine mm-hmm
can I look at bleh okay an aubergine is
our word for zucchini
I don't like zucchini okay avoid OB g mo
bazooms
okay Arbor jeans avoided bogey do you
know a bogey is bogey bad guy that what
fighter pilots there's a bogey on my
tail okay hit me
what is it means Booga so like a booger
in your nose a booger a booger a booger
a booger I don't know where that it's
gonna come in handy during a trick do
you know what a chav is a chav it was
explained to me that a chav was some
kind of teenage miscreant so chav is
typically a working-class person who
most of the time has a low ish
intelligence low ish who wears designer
label copies and fake gold bling and is
vivitrol maker if we see any a point
I'll point to Marty okay let's watch
average effed chuffed what does that
mean like I'm quite chuffed happy yeah
yeah nice one flapjack flapjack
sometimes if females have a flappy
breast that's not what it is but in
America or rather where I'm from females
with flappy breasts cuts be referred to
as having flapjacks
we don't have fun I'm trying to teach
you English okay sorry it's just like a
no cake boat cake bar yeah I've never
heard of that fat do don't fact means FA
FF v is this something dirty if I'm
faffing something I'm cleaning it
bad thing about is to just kind of not
really do anything in particular you
just kind of like menial tasks that they
really add up to anything important just
spent the day fatten around in my room
that's not a bit dirty
it does numpty numpty sounds like Humpty
Dumpty had an umpty no you didn't have
an empty LT Dumpty would have been an
empty
he is enough T yeah he's an empty an egg
I don't know what that word means so I
don't know why it's funny a numpty is
just a stupid person a stupid person so
are chavs numpties spiffing spiffing is
a verb and no Dan can something be
spiffing yep well that was spiffing well
cuz we say spiffy I mean no one actually
says spiffy but if he's like that was
spiffy spiffing it was a good thing that
has too many letters we chop them off
yes sir you know what slash means slash
ya know um just to get for a way I had a
slash that doesn't make any sense nosh
nosh the opposite of posh you're not
posh you're not you would eat nosh nosh
as a food no she's not a food no she's
food Marsh is food so all food is not
fit sexy yeah pretty much I know that
because I watched skins but you know a
Winkle is a Winkle no have a guess
you'll probably get this one a penis
yeah can you try to your best even
fright and do the upload to my video uh
you've just had the almost imponderable
joy of watching charlieissocoollike
which makes you like cool
now they thanks for bein in my video
good bye to the end